This is just another case we need to
substitute in new values for these two
quantities, money from all original orders
and money from canceled orders into this
expression using these other two
equations. As we learned about
substitution very early on in the course,
if we have a system of equations that we
know is allowed to work together and one
quantity in one of the equations is equal
to another quantity in another one of the
equations. We can replace that quantity
with the other way to express it. So in
the case of these equations that means we
can replace money from all our original
orders right here with this expression,
87w+72n.
Since this equation tells us that, that is
equal to the money from all the original
orders. We can do the same thing with the
money from the canceled orders or the
amount of money that Grant would have
gotten if these orders hadn't been
canceled. So we'll replace money from
canceled orders with 3w+12n.
So this is what the equation looks like if
we just replace that one word money from
canceled orders with the mathematical
expression we know that it's equal to. But
we need to do one thing to change this
equation. We need to add parenthesis
around 3w+12n.
Now the reason we need to do that is
because we know what we want to subtract
the entire amount of money that Grant
would have earned from the orders that are
now cancelled. So to show that this is one
quantity, one sum of money, the money he
would have earned from the wipers and the
money he would have earned from the
nozzles, we put parenthesis around it.